اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا
المساء
الاوكراني جبهه بخموت روسيا انتصار رمزيون
الكريم ام تغيير في مسار الحرب يهدد العمق
الاوكراني
وفي الملف الثانيه للنقاش ايران تعتقل
مجموعه مرتبطه باسرائيل على حدودها حرب
الظل نهج لتجنب المواجهه المباشره ام
تاكيد على استمرار التساع الفجوه بين
طهران وتل ابيب
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الاول
الترتيبات على خريطه المعركه في اوكرانيا
بدات تتغير بعدما فرض فصل الشتاء اسلوبه
روسيا تحقق مكاسب جديده في الميدانه وترفع
علمها على ارض اوكرانيه وتجدد رفع معنويات
قواتها وتؤكد حسم القطار لصالحها قوات
فاجنر وتحت غطاء جوي وصاروخي ومدفعي من
الجيش الروسي اعلنت انتصارها وسيطرتها على
باخموت الاستراتيجيه في معركه وصفت
بالاعنف والاكثر دمويه تصريحات متضاربه
صاحبت اعلن السيطره وتسببت بحاله من
الارباك سواء من الجانب الاوكراني وايضا
حتى من الجانب الروسي زلاسكي تاره يقر
ضمنيا بان قوه بلاده فقدت السيطره على
مدينه باخموت بعد معارك دامت لاشهر طويله
وتاره اخرى يقول ان المدينه في قلوبنا غير
ان الدفاع الاوكرانيه قالت انها ما زالت
تواصل ق
الرئيس الروسي بوتين صار عائله تهنئه قوات
فاجنر واعضاء الجيش الذين ساهموا في هذه
المعركه واصدر توجيهاته برفع اسماء ابطال
العمليه المتميزين لتقليدهم اوسمه الشرف
التي تستحقها كما قال ووفق مراقبين باخموت
مشاهدينا ومعركتها التي استمرت 240 يوما
قد تكون بدايه للحديث عن حوار بعد تسجيل
خسائر كبيره في الجنود والعتاد العسكري او
قد تكون كذلك بدايه تغيير في مسار الحرب
وطريقه مفتوحا للقوات الروسيه نحو العمق
الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
الاستراتيجيه تقع في الجزء الشمالي الشرقي
من مقاطعه دونياتك في اقليم دومباس تبعد
نحو 600 كيلومتر عن العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كييف تعد احد اهم محاور النقل للجيش
الاوكراني من مدينه كان نحو
مركز اللوجيسي رئيسي بالنسبه لروسيا تعتبر
خاصيه خط الدفاع الاول في دون باس معبر
للمدن الكبرى مثل
كراماتورسكي هي مهمه للروس بعد خسارتهم
مدينه ايزيون جنوبي منطقه
تعتبر المدينه بوابه للتوغل باتجاه خركيف
في العمق الاوكراني
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من دبي رياض
قهوجي الباحث في شؤون الامن والدفاع اهلا
بك من موسكو دكتور رولاندوفا المحلل
السياسي اهلا بك ومن
السابق اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من دبي معك استاذ رياض لفهمي
اهميه في الواقع هذه المنطقه بما انه
التصريحات التي رافقت ليس فقط نهايه ان
كانت هناك نهايه لمعركه ولكن حتى مع
انطلاق معركه باخموت سميت هذه المعركه
برمزيه في حين بعض الاخر قال بانه هي مهمه
وهي تفتح المجال العمق الاوكراني حظر تك
لماذا بخمت مهمه لهذه الدرجه على الارض
وكذلك حتى من خلال التصريحات وكان هناك
بروباجندا اعلاميه رافقت هذه التطورات
يريد ان يصور ان الجيش الروسي هو عاجز من
دون الفاكتنر لا يستطيع الجيش الروس تحقيق
اي شيء هي كانت رمز
لاهميه دخول فاجنر في المواجهه وانها تحقق
ما عجز عنه الجيش عندما اصطدمت بهذه
المقاومه الشديده الاوكرانيين بدات هناك
تظهر حجج حينها حينها انها لا تتلقى ذخائر
حين ان هناك مشاكل مع قيادات
كان هناك دفاع قوي جدا
مدينه بحجم بخموت تاخذ ثمانيه اشهر من جيش
يعتبر من اقوى جيوش العالم
للسيطره عليها يعني هذا هذه الفتره بنفسها
هي تظهر مدى العجز والضعف لدى الجانب
الروسي
الترويج الاعلامي فقط لاظهار فاغنر
واهميتها في الداخل الروسي ضمن الصراع
داخل القيادات الروسيه انما من ناحيه
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه فهي لا تحمل تلك
الاهميه التي يتكلم او يحاول الروسي ان
يظهرها يعني هي استراتيجيه
لها موقع محدود جدا حجم التقدم يعني ان
اردنا ان نرى ما المسافه التي تقدم فيها
الجيش الروسي منذ هجوم الشتاء وحتى اليوم
نتحدث عن بضع كيلومترات فقط وبالتالي
الاعلان عن السيطره على المدينه ليس بداء
اهميه خاصه مع المكاسب التي حققها
الاوكرانيين خلال الاسابيع الماضيه في
السيطره وطرد الروس من
المناطق التي تحيط بمخموت من الشمال ومن
الجنوب حضرتك استاذ رياض تتحدث وتؤكد على
يعني حتى مع انتصار الروس او مقاله ما
اعتبروه انتصار حضرتك تؤكد بانه هذه
المعركه هي تكشف عجز الجيش الروسي
وبروباندا يطلقها
بريكوجين ما رايك في هذا الكلام دكتور
لاند خاصه وان البعض يقول بانه هذه
المعركه كشفت ليس فقط
طول امد الحرب وعدم قدره الجيش على ختم
هذه الحرب منذ البدايه ولكن كذلك فضحت
قسمات جد حاده داخل قيادات الجيش الروسي
وبين قياده الجيش الروسي
وفاكنر هل كانت تستحق بخموت كل هذا
اعلام كانت تستحق لانها الاراء المتناقضه
وفي رايه المتواضعه
وامس الرئيس روسي حنا في الدرجه الاولى
بريجوجنر ثم القوات الميزانيه هذه النقطه
مهمه جدا يجب
لفت النظر اليها لان هذه التناقضات
بالفعل موجوده بين بريوجين وبين وزاره
الدفاع هناك انتقادات شديده للقياده
العسكريه
وبالمناسبه
القياده العسكريه لديها الان فرصه ان يعني
تبرر نوسها
وتدخل جميع هذه الانتقادات لان الان سيبدا
الهجوم الاوكراني المرتكب منذ زمن بعيد
ختما يجب ان ياخذوا ذلك
وسنشهد كيف ما هو مستوى المهاره القتاليه
للقياده الروسيه لحيه الاركان في كل حال
من احوال
قال ونفذ الرجل نفذ محمدته واليوم موجود
وجاهزا يسلم ضخمه
للقواته
نحن نتحدث عن قائد في النهايه هي شركه
فيها مرتزقه هم يعملون لصالح روسيا ولكن
اين الجيش الروسي اين
القوات العسكريه الروسيه من كل هذا
القوات العسكريه الروسيه هي تقف في الخط
طوله نحو 1000 كيلومتر يقولون انه هناك
بنو الخطوط الدفاعيه محصنه
وهم في الاستعداد
لقبول للتصدي للهجوم الاوكراني
المرتقب ولكن هنا تتضافر في هذا الصراع
الاوامر السياسيه لانه في رايي يعني هناك
تيار الحمايمه في روسيا يعني في مصلحته
تجميد هذا النظام والمصالحه وايضا هناك
الصقور كما يحدث
فقط صحيح ولكن فقط اسمح لي ان نشرك معنا
كذلك ضيفه من السفير
سفيره
هل اقنعك اولا ضيف يا سيد رولاند بالقول
بانه في النهايه الجيش الروسي له مهمه الد
فاع عن
الحدود وكذلك حتى عن جيوب هذه المنطقه
وفاكنير مكلله مهمه مسك الارض السيطره
عليها ومن ثم مسكها وثانيا لماذا تعتبر
بخموت مهمه كذلك حتى الاوكرانيين
تصريحاتكي كانت كثيره وحتى متناقضه
بخصوصها
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته تحيه طيبه من
اوكرانيا بصراحه لا استطيع نشاط
جيش روسي هو واقف بصراحه نحن نشاهد يوميا
تقريبا عشره هجومات في يوم على قوات
مصالحه اوكرانيه من قبل الجيش روسيا
كابوس للدار يعني بصفه تعمل في منطقه
وعاجز لتحقيق اي هجوم على قوات المسلحه
روسيا هناك على قوات مصالح اوكرانيا ولكن
تصريحات اركان اوكرانيا
الان داخل
عمليه عمليه
الهجوم قوات مصالحه اوكرانيا
لهدف تطويق منطقه محمود من الشمال هو مين
الجنوب بلده محمود يعني من الممكن مجموعه
في هذه العمليه التطويق سوف نرى في ولكن
نستطيع ان نقول بصفه عامه بان محمود هي
اصبحت مقبره جماعيه للجيش روسيا ومجموعه
عدد اخصائر الضخمه سؤال مطروح على هذا
النصر او خساره روسيه يعني
استلاء محمود
الخاصه ضخمه كانها كما افادت اركان
اوكرانيا بان اثناء وجوه الخسائر روسيه في
محمود اكثر من 60 الف جنديا يعني اكيد هذا
صحيح ولكن قد يقول لك بعضهم سافير بانه
هناك امر واقع كذلك هناك امر واقع يثبت
ويؤكد بان الروس في النهايه سيطروا مهما
كانت خسائرهم سيطروا على هذه المنطقه التي
اعتبرها الرئيس الاوكراني نفسه بانها تمهد
للدخول للعمق الاوكراني طيب خلينا نفهم
اولا موقف الرئيس الاوكراني لانه لم يفهمه
البعض هو تناقض حتى في توصيفه لهذه
التطورات الرئيس الاوكراني رغم رفع فاجنر
لعلم روسيا داخل باخموت الا انه اعتبر
بانه اوكرانيا لم تخسر الارض نذكر
بتصريحاته مشاهدينا من خلال هذا الفاصل
ومن ثم نعود
اليوم يقومون بمهمه بالغه الاهميه وهم في
بخموت حتى اليوم ولكن لن اخبرك في اي موقع
بالضبط لكن هذا يعني ان بخمت لم يتم
احتلالها من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
لم يبقى في ضخمه اي جندي اوكراني لاننا لا
نجد من يمكننا اخذه في الاسر وهناك عدد
كبير من جثث الجيش الاوكراني زيلينسكي
ماكر وليس على علم بما يحدث على الارض
ساعود لتصريحات بريغوجين قائد فاجنر حينما
وصف رئيس الاوكراني بالماكر او بانه لا
يعلم ماذا يحدث ولكن اسمح لي سيد رياض ان
اقف معك على تصحيح التي يقول فيها بان
باخموت لم يحتلها الجانب الروسي كيف نفهم
هذا التصريح والواقع يقول بان روسيا فعلا
سيطرت على هذه المنطقه هل هي رساله للغرب
هل فقدان باخموت احرج الذي تسلم
ما لم يتسلمه احد مساعدات عسكريه من الغرب
اعتقد ان الوضع الميداني على الارض اليوم
هو دانيميكي بشكل كبير من ناحيه ان هناك
عمليات عسكريه مستمره لم تنتهي العمليات
العسكريه في منطقه بخموت هناك هجمات تقوم
بها الاوكرانيين من الشمال من الجنوب ايضا
اتوقع ان يكون هناك محاولات للتسلل بعض
الاحياء في في بخموت لاستمرار في عمليه
الاستنزاف
لاناصر فاكتور انما التكتيك الاساسي
الواضح من الجانب الاوكراني انهم يقومون
اليوم بادخال
داخل المدينه ومن ثم محاوله تطويق المدينه
في حال نجحوا في هذه تصبح تعتبر بخمه
ساقطه عسكريا لصالح اوكرانيا
لانها تم تطويقها من المناطق الاساسيه من
الشمال من الجنوب ويبقى فقط الناحيه
الشرقيه للمدينه التي من جانب القوات
الروسيه في حال اتم الطوق بشكل كامل تسقط
المدينه عسكريا
ديناميكي هناك
تطورات عسكريه على الارض وبالتالي قد يكون
فاجنان السيطره على الاحياء والجزء
المتبقي من بخموت انما لا يعني انه بات
مسيطر بشكل تام على مدينه بخموت والمناطق
المحيطه بها ان بقيت شمال وجلب المدينه في
يد الاوكرانيين فهي المدينه عرضه لان يتم
استعادتها من الاوكران في اي لحظه ولكن
يعني حضرتك تقول بانه ما لم يتم او تتم
السيطره على الجيوب والمحيط فانه يجب ان
نقول بان المعركه مستمره ولكن مهما تكن
اطاله امد هذه المعركه البعض قال بانه
كما تدين الروس تدين كذلك الاوكرانيين
الاوكران الذين نتحصلوا على كميه اسلحه
مهمه جدا من الغرب هل هذا التطور الاخير
لصالح الروس يحرج زيلنسكي سيد رياض
باختصار ان تكرمت
اعتقد انا زعلان
تعمد اظهار او التركيز على بخموت بهدف
استنزاف هناك
تركيز كبير روسي بسبب التي
اعطيت لهذا الموضوع على المدينه وبالتالي
تحولت المدينه الى
مطحنه
للقوات الروسيه في حين ان هناك تحضير
لهجوم مضاد كبير على جبهات اخرى خاصه في
الجنوب هنا التركيز الاوكراني فبخموت هي
هي نقطه للاستنزاف انما الهدف الاستراتيجي
لاي عمل عسكري او للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
يتوقع ان يكون في مناطق اكثر اهميه خاصه
نحو
طيب دكتور رولاند هل يمكن ان تكون المعركه
معركه باخموت او على الاقل ما الت اليه
التطورات فيما يخص باق موت هو باب يفتح
لفرز طاوله مفاوضات على كل الاطراف تعلم
حضرتك بان الارض تقرر طاوله المفاوضات
زمانها وتوقيتها خاصه هل الوقت سنحل
الحوار
ابدا للاسف الشديد الامور وصلت الى نقطه
حيث الحلول العسكريه هي السائده وفي
ديناميكا
كما قال الزميل
لن تكون هناك الان اي مفاوضات لان الغرب
مصمم لدعم الاوكرانيه حتى النهايه وروسيا
لا تريد ان ترضخوا لشروط الغرب
وتسحب قواتها من
هذه الاراضي خاصه بعدما اجريت هناك
الاستطلاعات
وصوتت هناك السكان لصالح ضمها الى روسيا
واصبحت وفقا للقانون الروسي اجزاء من
روسيا اذا الحاله في مازق سياسيين وكذلك
في مازق ايسكريم بالمناسبه كل شيء لذي قيل
حول ان هي المراه المتقنه واستنزاف ناس
الكلام يقول انه اله من هذه العمليه من
ضخمه كان
استنزاف ومطحنه ومفرمه اللحوم للجيش
الاوكراني يعني كلاء الطرفين يتخذان
بعضهما البعض ولديهم الرواياتان
المتناقضتان اما
المؤسسات العسكريه والخبراء العسكريون
يراقبون الوضع انكتب ويجب
الانتظار الهجوم المرتقب وغيرها من الامور
وسنشهد قريبا كيف ستتطور الاحداث يعني
بحسب رايك المعارك لن تنتهي ما رايك
هل هناك مجال لطويله حوار في هذه الاثناء
او انك تتفق مع ضيفنا من روسيا بان
المعارك لن تتوقف حتى وان كانت على حساب
العمق الاوكراني كما نفهم من تصريحات رئيس
لانس كان الذي يتخوف على كراماتورس وعلى
كذلك بعد ضخمه
من الممكن اي مفاوضات ارهابيين اكيد لا
وافاد من الممكن اي مفاوضات مع رؤوس بعض
طرد رؤوس من اراضي اوكرانيا وانا موافق مع
بصراحه مهمه جدا يعني روسيا من الممكن من
الممكن هي ترغب المفاوضات ولكن هي لها
ترغب السلام عندي الشواغل جديه بين روسيا
سوف تستخدم المفاوضات لتعزيز قواتها
لتحقيق تعبيط العامه بعد ذلك روسيا سوف
تهاجم على اوكرانيا الان هدف روسيا
وعدم خروج اوكرانيا من منطقه نفوز روسيه
روسيا ما تحتاج بصفه عامه جنوب اوكرانيا
وكمان هي تحتاج
اوكرانيا بهذا صعبه بروسيا هجمت على
اوكرانيا وخاصه في بدايه حرب هدف اساسي
عند بوتين ولكن روسيا سوف تفاشل في هذا
القضيه لان قضيه عادله نحن نقاتل معروف من
اجل تحرير ارادنا من من جيش عدوان روسي
ممكن روسيا تطلب مفاوضات ولكن كما نقول هي
لا تطلب السلام نحن نشاهد بان روسيا
بشكل منهجي
على مدن اوكرانيا روسيا تدامر بنيه تغطيه
سكنيه في اوكرانيا للاسف الشديد
الوقت بما اننا كنا نتابع
وصول او رحله الى الفضاء
اياد او بحضور سعودي فاخذنا مجال لمتابعه
هذه التفاصيل ولكن ستكون لنا لقاءات اخرى
لمتابعه هذه التطورات كذلك اود شكركم من
دبي رياض قهوجي الباحث في شؤون الامن
والدفاع من موسكو دكتور رولانوفا المحلل
السياسي ومن السفير فولو ديمير شوماك و
فاديبلوماسي السابق شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات